hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make a huge update guys on amc
we had some very interesting price
action movement yesterday we also had
some news so we're gonna have a look at
everything and we're gonna try to see
what impact this could have on the
future price action let's get into it
[Music]
all right so i think it's a big day guys
so where should i start okay daily time
frame i think you guys all saw that but
i'm just gonna do it very quickly again
one two
three
four and i think we're doing a fifth
wave that will go to 130 roughly this is
my level so in this fifth wave we're
trying to find five waves as well i mean
this is the elliott wave theory little
game and here it's pretty obvious first
wave here second wave a bit longer than
deeper than expected and
this looks to me like the beginning of
the third wave so i'm gonna stay for now
on the daily timeframe like i told you
guys on discord the day before we had
here a little bullish engulfing so why i
call it little because usually those
bullish and things that powerful
whenever they are at the bottom of a
downtrend here the downtrend was rather
here so by the way this is a very nice
bullish engulfing
okay so i think i have spoken about this
one as well this one was here also
breaking out so here we have here a
beautiful one that is going to impact
the future press action so i think that
this is what we're seeing and here we
have a small one so once again bullish
engulfing is whenever we open below
yesterday's close so here we closed at
36.8 and we open at 35.7 so below and we
closed above yesterday open i mean two
days ago open so this was i think
bullish signal that got followed by a
massive move up technically we are
bullish we are above the 50 and 20 day
moving averages the last time guys this
happened was here all right here we
broke above the 20 and then above the 50
and we had this whole move up that went
to the 52 area so it looks to me like
this is what is going to happen but let
me analyze a bit further if you check
the news you're going to find that we
have an increase of direct registration
accounts so if i check at the news we
have some interesting information in
recent days an increasing number of
retail investors have swapped the
torches pitchforks and td ameritrade
accounts for direct registration
platforms like computer cpu blah blah
blah so what does it mean it means that
right now investors can directly own
their share so they physically own it
which means they can agree or not to
land it when before i mean still right
now but whenever you trade through robin
hood or whatever broker those guys
they're gonna keep your shares on their
accounts and they're going to lend it to
short sellers for a fee that we call the
reaper rate so this vicious circle can
keep happening but if all the apes
physically hold their shares and they
don't land it short sellers are gonna
run short of shares to sell so this is
very positive and i think that this
together associated with the bullish
engulfing gave us the power we needed to
break here so what may we expect from
now i would like to remind you guys that
covering the stock for almost one year
and i would like to remind you where i
was really bullish so basically
when did i start i started to cover it
here so i was here very bullish the
whole way up okay let's be honest here i
was bullish and then we got rejected but
then here guys you can check my videos i
was saying for a few weeks amc will go
to 35 35 35 i was repeating that once we
reached that i immediately said we're
going to go to 65 and then correct 237
all right so basically i was bullish
here
then here i was neutral bearish i was
bullish at the beginning i was hoping we
go right away to 135 which didn't happen
and then here we had a lot of bearish
signals i gave you that guys and then
what happened we had here one fake out
okay i was in this fakeout i was of
course calling for a strong move up at
that time so it was here guys but then
quickly it was not looking great and i
told you as well that
roughly when we were below 36 37
and second time i called for strong move
up was here guys and this one worked
very well
and we broke out we tested the level and
then we moved higher we completed five
ways then once we were there i told you
guys and you can check my videos even if
the thumbnail are always very bullish
because this is how this game work this
youtube game but if you check inside the
video what i'm saying i was here telling
you that it would probably correct and i
was targeting 38. we went slightly below
and here for the past two weeks i'm
calling again for a strong move up why
because it looks to me that right now we
have completed this correction and we
are going higher so i'm calling for it
and this is the confirmation to me that
we are heading in the right direction so
what i'm just would like to show you
guys here is that
usually when those signals happen so
let's say they happened five times in
the past they were positive so we had
two fake outs all right
but the all the other times it was
positive and
and it gave us the reactions we were
waiting for so here what we can do is
check how much gamma we have because you
guys know that today is an expiry day so
let's check
and i have checked that already okay but
i'm gonna do it with you again but i
know what i'm gonna find is that the 40
and the 45 strikes on the october
maturity are huge all right
so
first thing here guys the breakdown or
the breakdown of the option market by
strike you can see the huge amount of
shares we have the 145 strikes so 16
million so it's basically roughly the
same what i'm looking at guys is the
maximum synthetic short so right now we
are at 20
so we were at 20 25 so we're roughly
where we usually are but what is
interesting is to see here okay so the
40 strike is full okay and where is it
coming from
it's coming from here mostly all right
you see the biggest position okay jan 22
as well but we have a lot of 40 strikes
coming from october which is tomorrow
guys i mean today so this is gonna give
us a lot of gamma okay guys and as you
can see it is not small at all compared
to the biggest one we have so it's
really big and if amc starts to move
higher there's gonna be this bullish
momentum being at play
so for all these reasons technically we
have a breakout okay short-term breakout
here so first reason to be bullish with
the bullish engulfing so this is gonna
give us some energy for the coming two
weeks we didn't really see it but right
now we have a smaller bullish engulfing
we close above the 20 and 50 day moving
average which last time it happened
triggered a strong move up we have the
option expiry today and we have this
positive news so we have everything to
me that is pointing to one direction is
that we are going to have some massive
moves up come so let's see let's find
out if we manage to keep control this
time if bears are not just reloading
let's see everything can happen but i'm
very positive for the coming day and the
coming weeks
so that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys